à tous les engins des phobies avant
d'accueillir bertrand chamerois bien sûr
à 19h58 très précise bertrand chamerois
qui nous montrera un nouvel épisode
d'house of crade pour le moment les
phobies alors vous avez tous des phobies
autour de cette table allez vous pouvez
revenir un l et les deux écoles et dieu
[Applaudissements]
ce sont les invités qui vont jouer donc
d'accord je vous montre des phobies et
vous allez me dire à qui elle appartient
attention c'est parti
mettez la liste des phobies merci c'est
tout alors voilà il ya il ya une
personne autour de la table qui a peur
des manèges
à votre avis qui a peur des manèges à la
même deux il y en a deux qui ont qui ont
des idées des finances marie-mai ses
marines et luan à votre avis qui a peur
des manèges autour de la table elles
sont dans la liste les filles mais en
version dans la liste rouge
tyrrell ou non mais aussi les deux
filles soient pas d'accord alors
marinello appris à perdre et manèges
penser que c'est qu' autour de la table
il y en a deux c'est de ces deux mecs je
vous le dis vous dédié à l'or est la
peur des malaises autour de la table
allez-y vous jetez vous à l'eau
merci et vive marine vous pensez que
c'est qu'ils avaient bien digéré ni la
olic a peur des baleines m'appelle déjà
laouni vous avez peur déballage ou moi
j'ai pas peur des mots noirs s'étirent
et winnipeg
c'est très beau et julien courbet
faisait plein des manèges lui depuis un
saut en élastique au dessus de bordeaux
pour une émission pour france rouges
avaient accepté de faire ça la grue
était à 60 mètres et depuis j'ai le
vertige et dès que ça tourne etc
mais je deviens fou dans c'est vrai
c'est à bordeaux ça c'est à bordeaux on
a les images non et si regardez on a le
saut à l'élastique de julien courbet de
ces deux fous c'est vrai regardez il ya
25 ans nous sommes en direct ici sur le
port de bordeaux
je pensais que j'étais un homme super
courageux et bien je suis bien déçu de
voir que j'ai une sacrée trouille à 7,4
du sol référence aux pour faire plaisir
à mon producteur adoré pour lui montrer
que je suis pas une mauviette
alors peut-être à jamais peut-être à
tout à l'heure pour une après-midi en
tout cas très enflammée on est préservé
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
petit continuer et que j'ai pas dû faire
ça mais pas du vin mission impossible
est celle où j'ai adopté en fait cloud
cavale et a demandé qu'un manège qui
tourne au déclin de la hauteur mais j'ai
la trouille mêmes examens quand même un
petit fantôme quand même tu te rends
compte au bout et on va se faire en
sorte d'en bas très bien qui à votre
avis à la phobie des clowns blancs la
phobie des clowns blancs autour de la
table et pourquoi blanc balas cahill et
voilà il ya derrière ça découle borie
les aime pas oui il y avait jean michel
qui aimait pas les gagnants et les
maliens à riom et autour de la table
alors à votre avis le ruc jean-louis
vous dirait jean luc lemoine ce que vous
avez peur des clowns blancs rouges et
bien voilà c'est ces vigiles
ah oui à quoi sert vous avez vraiment
peur des coups devant terrifié voix
c'est-à-dire dès que vous voyez un coût
de l'eau à ben je peux pas quoi j'ai je
pense qu'il va me poignarder qui va me
mettre anglais qui gère le maquillage
blanc d'un cloud ça me terrifie les crs
à supporter ça ah ouais ça tombe de toi
aussi vous faites quoi combien coûte
blot jeu je m'attendais je les laisse
vite on est jamais vu une crise et
depuis j'en ai vu à la télé mes parents
m'avaient abandonné j'ai cassé la vitre
pour fuir je pense que je suis je peux
plus c'est l'avis de la télé ça fait
quoi la vie de la maison j'ai fui je me
suis alors j'ai failli mourir parce que
je me suis mis les les
les poignets dans la vie tellement
j'avais peur ah ouais quand même pas
vrai donc ça va est-ce que je peux
quitter l'émission
qui a peur des serpents
autour de la table qui a peur des
serpents il y en a un ou une qui a très
très peur des serpents il a vraiment la
phobie des serpents marine non à ces
infos beat fille quand même thème
non vous vous avez peur de klose 1 c'est
ça j'ai plein de choses moi non mais
rien non plus penser et n'aura qu'à peur
des serpents
non c'est pas une aura c'est là au nid
c'est la fouine a capela des salles est
vraiment peur des serpents en main en
tant que rappeur je n'ai peur de rien
mais vraiment il fallait voilà donc j'ai
un peu peur d'eux j'ai pas peur des
soeurs malheureusement on n'a pas perdre
de serpents je le dis parce qu'on n'a
pas le droit non mais soyez sûr le
plateau n'a pas le droit mais on en a eu
un sourire gentier toutes ces nouvelles
surfaces d'un ferry temps du spectacle
aux bretons dans toutes les émissions
préférées
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je dois de loi de mai chez mym et une
chambre à l'oeil mais son chèque fait
pas peur j'ai peur de ça il a touché
aller s'il vous plaît j'ai peur de mal à
me séparer
ouais il était julien s'est barré à midi
moi tu te fais exprès non j'aimerais
j'ai vraiment pas peur moi j'adore les
serpents elle est sortie deux ans avec
un serpent et 3 à 3,3 g une peur de
mettre la tête sous l'eau qui a peur de
mettre la tête sous l'eau et qui a peur
de mettre la tête sous l'eau bien
évidemment il avait expliqué je frise
c'est pour ça que j'ai aura laissé
prendre
avant d'indiquer a peur de mettre la
tête sous l'eau va lancer sa phobie des
pêches lenovo isabelle ac n'aura senora
c'est vrai que j'ai fait du surf quand
j'étais petit j'ai failli me noyer et
depuis
vraiment c'est impossible pour moi quand
je nage de mettre la tête sous l'eau
j'ai l'impression que j'ai crevé c'est
impossible je vais les gens paniqués qui
rit aussi pareil parce que quand j'étais
gamin j'ai commencé à apprendre à nager
quand j'étais au bord de la mer et en
rentrer une fois chez moi ma mère a
voulu continuer à me faire prendre des
cours j'étais dans une piscine marcher
au bord de la piscine
le mec maître nageur était un militaire
il a dit ben on va voir ce qu'il sait
faire il m'a poussé non c'est pas une
loyer le militaire est là ce soir et moi
c'est pareil j'ai peur de l'eau parce
que mon père à ses yeux noyés quand
j'étais petit alors qu'ils aient les
mygales qui est les mygales une personne
ici qui est les montagnes ses marines et
barry d'un marine faisait détester les
mygales c'est qu'elle est vraiment vous
détestez les mygales chaleur c'est rien
que là je fais pas fait un mois que tout
ça était là la regarder syria alors ça
c'est juste un petit nice à settat pas
ça c'est un palet dans la boîte
ouais mais bon rien lâché non non je le
fais ouais ouais ouais
masi d'accord bbq
[Musique]
elle est super gentil j'adore les
mygales et j'adore ça allait super aqua
ses boxes à saint gilles vu que vous
faites
oui mais vous faites avec tout l est
trop mignon mais c est trop bien je veux
dire moi j'adore les mygales j'adore
j'adore la lafam d'ailleurs la mygale et
la fourmi vie vous fait le test avec
tous ceux qui ont peur en fait j'ai
changé ma peur j'ai vraiment super plan
quand une femme nue vient me lécher le
ventre loi
luan elle n'a pas peur des médias ligne
à la pas peur des serpents
elle a une phobie est la peur des
bananes vous avez peur des ballades mais
un truc de fou j'aimerais pour ça alors
il fallait que moi moi malheureusement
j'ai toujours une banane chambre
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
non non non mais qu'est ce qui se passe
les images si vous voyez une balade quoi
tu as eu très peur des bananes il sait
aussi phobie des ballades mais ça
s'appelle ça s'appelle la banane ou la
banane aux femmes la banane of à
villabona nos phobies
mais il a eu un traumatisme je sais pas
je ne sais pas la bête là quoi c'est
vrai ça va aller vite et vous voyez une
banane neuron ça c'est pire que c'est
pire que tout le monde ici c'est vrai et
quant au coût de banana split de lio
pareil tu vois quoi c'est vrai quoi
meslois vraiment non mais c'est vrai il
paraît que c'est vrai je laisse aller je
les cache et je les cas ces jeux les
cafés les lois de casser non elle veut
pas voir sa famille gelés katché doit de
les cacher c'est bon la place en mai et
celui de mes tongs château quand vous
passez devant devant devant des balades
au marché vous imaginez nous allons
marcher seul hier elle pas ça dépote
débal'art non mais ça m'a inscrit pas je
pleure pas tout va bien mais c est quand
vous envoyez à la télé même des bananes
z'avez vu un film d'horreur avec des
bananes vers mais comme ça comme il y
avait la tacc de la banane géante crois
que ça a tué non mais c'est que chacun
ses phobies c'est une phobie un peu
bizarre c'est vrai mais bon est vraiment
vous pouvez pas la regarder la banane
sérieusement
one c'est bon c'est bon c'est bon on va
cueillir d'arrageois
[Applaudissements]
allez c'est bon c'est bon on l'accueille
vert on accueille mercredi à nauroy pour
l'acquérir trop sympa
[Musique]